this was a highly active and flourishing
intellectual environment Spain had been
a place where Jews Muslims and
Christians had lived together for
centuries under Islamic Rule and while
this situation of course wasn't without
its conflicts and tensions it had been a
time and place of unusual levels of
cross-pollination and inspiration across
religious lines philosophers like IB
bajah IB tfil and IB Rush on the Muslim
side worked alongside Jewish thinkers
and inspired many of them such as the
massively important Moses myones on the
Jewish side furthermore Sufism often
called Islamic mysticism had also become
quite popular and widespread in the
region and already by the 12th century
we see Jewish writers clearly being
influenced by Sufi piety and practice
such as B pakas
Al the duties of the heart a book
essentially on ethics and spiritual SL
mystical practice